well the question I would repeatedly get
when I was conduct
public meetings in Indiana was where are
the leaders it's the question you just
asked and I think it's on the minds of
an awful lot of Americans where are the
Lincoln's The Jeffersons the
Washington's I don't know that I know
the answer to that but I think part of
the answer may be that the country is
just a lot more complicated a lot more
difficult to govern today because of its
size and because of its diversity
because of the acceleration if you would
of life and the political skill that is
most needed in this presidential
election or any political election from
my point of view is the ability to build
consensus behind a solution it's not
very hard really to walk into a room of
people or you're discussing a difficult
issue and blow it apart I know it's not
very hard because I've done it on a few
occasions what is really hard is to walk
into that room and to build a consensus
behind a solution to the problem that
you're talking about that is political
skill and that is the skill most needed
in this great big diverse complicated
country with all of these conflicting
interests that we have consensus
building that's what I look for in a
politician
you